- [Voiceover] This is the
third video in a series
about tackling the Long Essay Question
on the AP U.S. History exam.
Now in the last video we were kind of
weighing the evidence about the New Deal.
Considering the ways in
which the government,
the economy and race, class and gender,
may have been either conservative during
the New Deal or radical.
And we came up with some good evidence
to support either side.
And now it's up to me to choose which way
I'm going to go.
So I think I'm actually
going to choose the
conservative side here
because I think it's
just a tiny bit more convincing.
And if you're wondering why I think it's
a tiny bit more convincing,
I think the part about
Eleanor Roosevelt being
an advocate for race and
Frances Perkins being a
visible woman in a government cabinet,
they to me don't seem like
maybe substantive changes.
They seem maybe like they're
a little bit more like
figure heads like things
went well for this one person
or maybe just a tiny group of people,
but in the grand scheme
of things it wasn't
that big of a change.
Anyway, you may feel different from me.
You may decide that you would have written
an article about how
radical the New Deal was,
but I'm going to do an example
of a conservative argument
about the New Deal.
Now our task here is take
these themes that we've noticed
and the evidence that
we have assembled about
these themes and turn it
into a five paragraph essay.
And that essay is going
to include an introduction
with a thesis statement
and a paragraph that
explores one of these themes,
and I think I might start
with the government theme.
A paragraph that explores another one.
I think I'll go with the economic theme.
And because we're talking
about economics here,
I actually think we're going
to roll class into that one
because it's about people who are rich
and people who are poor.
And lastly I want to
talk about the effect on
woman and minorities.
So that's our last theme.
And then we'll finish it
all up with a conclusion
where we talk about how right we were.
All right. Are you ready for this?
So let's start with our thesis statement.
So we've decided that we
think that the New Deal
was ultimately conservative.
So we could start our
introduction by saying,
"Although the New Deal
seems really radical
"because it brought on a
new relationship between
"the federal government
and the economy and
"there were so many new programs.
"In fact, it was actually
essentially conservative.
"And it was conservative
because it did not really change
"the essence of American government,
"the America economy,
"or the lives of ordinary
Americans including
"women and minorities."
All right. I think that's pretty good.
So let's move into our first paragraph
about the government.
Now with our thesis
statement here we've kind of
set up a pattern for
ourselves to say the things
that seem radical,
but really are conservative.
And we're going to do that
in each of these paragraphs.
So we can say what seems radical.
Specific examples of things
that might seem radical.
And it's in giving these
specific examples where
you're going to really
wow the reader by showing
the breadth of your knowledge.
So it might seem radical that there's
a whole new government
bureaucracy around the economy.
It might even seem radical
that there are women
in cabinet positions.
It might even seem radical
that FDR had this kind of
first 100 days thing where he said,
"I'm going to achieve so
much in my first 100 days.
"I'm going to hit the ground running."
So that seems like a very
different form of government
than what you might have had in the 1920s.
In fact you can even
say that FDR is such a
active President, right?
Mean he is bringing a force of personality
and also governing
ability to this role that
really hadn't been established that much
except for, you know, a few people say
Lincoln or Teddy Roosevelt.
So it does seem like
he's changing the office
of President quite a bit,
but in fact it's really
conservative because they're not
throwing the baby out
with the bathwater, right.
They're saying that essentially
the democratic system works,
and you can even compare
the American government
with governments in other
parts of the world right now.
I mean think about Germany
where this economic depression
leads to the rise of Hitler.
So the United States could
conceivably have become
a fascist government in this time period,
but they did not.
All right. Let's talk about economics and
the class system in the United States.
So first let's think about
things that might seem radical.
Well it's radical that the
government puts together
all of these new economic
initiatives like social security,
or the federal deposit
insurance corporation, the FDIC,
which are new regulations
about the banking and
economic system that are kind of designed
to make sure that ordinary
people don't lose everything
if the banking system
crashes or maybe if they're
in old age and lose their job.
And there's also a new
sense that being wealthy is
not something that's
necessarily deserved, right.
That there's an element
of chance that goes
into your economic status.
So I think it really
tears down a long standing
stereotype in the United
States that the wealthy
deserve to be wealthy and
the poor deserve to be poor,
this is a very popular
notion in the gilded age.
And instead says,
"You know, sometimes bad
things happen to good people."
It's not everyone's fault
if there's a depression
because we couldn't have stopped it.
Now we can to talk about how
it was really conservative.
And what we're saying here is that the
capitalist system itself
didn't fall apart.
If you compare the New
Deal to a true revolution,
like for example the French Revolution,
or the Russian Revolution,
and these are examples where the poor
rose up against the rich
and were cutting people's
heads off and taking their land.
Then the New Deal seems very conservative.
In fact,
what most of these New Deal programs
are trying to do is not
to demolish capitalism,
but to fix capitalism.
So they accept the basic
premise that capitalism is good.
And that certainly wasn't the
case in many other countries
in the time period.
Okay, last paragraph.
So again we're looking
at things that seem like
they might be radical.
And you could say,
"It seems like Frances
Perkins and Eleanor Roosevelt
"are women that have
established a real presence
"in the government."
And you could say that,
"New Deal programs did
employ many African Americans
"and at the national
level were not intended
"to be discriminatory."
But you could say,
"At the local level administrators
are often preventing
"African Americans and other
minorities from getting jobs."
And you could also say that,
"A lot of the New Deal programs
"were really definitely intended for men."
And you could, for example, say,
"The Civilian Conservation
Core was a program only
"for young men."
So women are often
booted out of these jobs
or they're not even
actually eligible for them
in the first place.
So even though the New
Deal is supposed to be
this great economic turnaround
in the United States,
it really doesn't change
the status of women
and minorities much at all.
Okay, time to conclude.
So I think we can pretty much just sum up
what we've said here.
That there are a lot of things
that look really radical
about the New Deal,
but in the end it doesn't
actually change that much
about the basic assumptions
and basic structure
of the American society and economy.
And you might even mention that it's not
going to be for another 20 or 30 years
that things like this change
for women and minorities.
And even during the 1940s things,
things kind off go back to
the status quo before the
great depression, right.
It's this moment during the New Deal
where there are a lot of
government experiments
about how to reorganize American society
and reorganize the American economy,
but by 1940 things kind
of go back to the way
that they had been.
They're only a few things
that still remain with us
from the New Deal and I think those things
are important like the
FDIC, social security,
and the idea of an
interventionist government
in the first place.
But from the 1920s to the 1940s,
there's not a gigantic revolution,
an American Democracy, capitalism,
or social structure.
Things continue the way that they were
and that's why the New Deal
is essentially conservative.
Okay, well I hope this
example helped you with a
Long Essay portion of
the AP U.S. History exam
and good luck.